hey guys so uh we just watched black
widow
[Laughter]
and it uh yes uh so like we're gonna
shoot our review in a bit and
uh it's gonna be attached to the
reaction for
the movie i imagine we're going to be
talking for a long time yes there are
thoughts
yes which we will try to condense as
efficiently as possible here from our
discussion during the credits
i think we're fairly on the same page
yeah marvel's not going to be paying us
a check this time because we
you know we just got to be honest here
now this this is not going to hit their
required talking points
look i know how these go if we come on
here being like
everyone's going to be like you guys
love everything which i hear constantly
and they clearly haven't seen some
brother videos
and then uh if i come on here talking
crap about a movie
uh you know it's like some people are
going to be mad right away when i'm like
well
dude you want to be mad about us giving
our opinion uh you haven't seen the
movie we have
all right most of you haven't most of
you are going to be upset about us
being honest about some things you
haven't seen it maybe when you do see it
and you disagree with us
then fine totally valid awesome sorry
we're not giving the opinion
you might be looking for to validate an
anticipation
no you hate me that's it that's all it
is okay book positives for sure
florence pugh as yelena i kind of just
expected her to be good because florence
pugh i wasn't expecting to love her
so early on in this movie and be
incredibly excited
incredibly excited about elena yeah she
is
astounding she is the best part of this
movie they don't even like force
her
partly because she's just so naturally
just kind of there
he's a dramatic weight she brings the
great levity totally lived
in for all the crazy stuff they're
asking her to do for the first time
we're seeing her do it
there's a lot of action in this movie
one might argue too much
there's a lot of action in this movie
when you guys see our reaction you know
i'm sure there'll be a thumbnail of us
looking excited in some way right
uh just because there are moments that
truly generate that there are moments
especially in the action scenes
especially in the comedy moments that
really hit the action itself there's a
good variety of it
from car chases to some great practical
stunts
some great choreography too and a good
mixture of it all the performers are
great
rachel weiss yeah i mean the main core
ensemble of like david harbor rachel
weiss florence pugh and scarlett
johansson especially a really good
together
regardless of any other part of the
movie they are always really doing a
great job with the
uh performance and just feeling like an
ensemble with some history together
sure taskmaster's okay yeah
you know you know taskmaster's in there
he's in there somewhere really cool
stuff yeah can't say too much there's
nuanced lived-in performances in this
movie that really help
elevate a lot uh of the film and the
music's really good the movie itself
is okay i think it's an okay movie but
it's fun
it's always the safety thing to say
right but it's funny but the the thing
though is is that it is fun like it's
like that's
that's the thing is it is actually fun
it's fun enough that there's still
stuff that you'll enjoy but ultimately a
big part of me actually felt a little
disappointed because
this is black widow's standalone movie
when people are saying what's the point
in the marketing why
she's already gone yeah this movie
didn't i did not feel like this movie
justified
yeah it doesn't it doesn't nail the
point because the shadow of the doubt
yeah you know like it it gets it it gets
close sometimes constantly is
constantly in a state of taking this
movie's constantly close together
right when i'm like oh we're gonna hit
some altitude we're gonna get into some
meaty stuff yeah there's another action
scene
surprise we don't have time for anything
it's constantly it's a lot of missed
potential i think in some ways i got
what i expected so i'm not like
bummed but at the same time yes it does
leave you wishing that they
went further expanded harder and paid
off
more succinctly and more emotionally
than they do it just sacrificed
a lot of where i feel to just be an
entertaining flick i could see the
outline
there's a lot of text here that's
telling me what to feel
but the themes are but you're not diving
enough into scenes
of why i should just feel this way
instead of being like here's information
it's a very emotionally challenging
story and set of circumstances that
doesn't actually feel very emotionally
challenging
yes which i guess is my biggest
complaint about the entire experience
yeah i didn't really feel much a lot of
this comes down to feeling
other than when the action was cool or
there was some like whoa that's violent
or comedy moments
there's only a couple of isolated
moments where i was really felt
something
yeah for the most part not so much i
think there's
i think there's just way too much action
especially in like the first hour of
this movie here's the thing it's like
sounds like a weird complaint you're
talking about marvel movie of course
there's gonna be action but you gotta
temper that
you gotta temper it you gotta earn your
scenes instead of just like
dang there's so much here and i kind of
if you're telling me this is the black
widow standalone movie we've been
waiting for
for all these years we've been waiting
for it and potentially this being her
swan song too
it deserved better storytelling there's
a good outline here
there's a lot of potential it's just the
meat of the script
and this but especially where i think it
really falters the direction of the
scenes that are not
action and the editing of those scenes
this movie had
tonal problems and pacing problems i
think this is the best
scarlett johansson natasha romanov
performance she's ever
given undoubtably yet weirdly
she shines less than a lot of the other
performers
it's a kind of this weird paradox there
are other characters around who are
either new or just much more big and
boisterous and whatnot
i mean she yeah she certainly leaves an
impact but in the same breath i guess in
a send-off movie i would have hoped
for myself a bit more catharsis and a
bit more rectification of the harsh
aspects of natasha's life yes i think
this movie very apparently
like quite apparently was really holding
back
uh in terms of how dark it could have
been you really
want to push the envelope but you're so
not you don't want to feel a punch being
pulled because there's so many
great themes that are established and
there are a lot of great
challenging contexts for these
characters to
either rectify from the past or confront
in the now
it did ultimately feel like yeah for
whatever reason they
didn't pay those off in a very cathartic
way or in a way that was very
lived in or that it seemed like it
wanted to spend a lot of time walking
around
and not that this needs to be a full-on
character study but at the same time the
place on the timeline this falls in
it is pretty much action action action
and when it slows down
to have a scene it doesn't really know
how to just capture a good scene that
taken three meme of them going over the
fence i'm like why is this happening
during the dialogue scene
yeah yeah it starts to feel like the
most of the movie has
one approach to editing whereas some
kind of variation in the flow and pace
could have
helped i didn't understand the intention
of it it was like watching a movie that
was trying to be a paul greengrass movie
sort of who are you or you're like
let these scenes breathe and so i could
feel something
there's so much plot happening and yet
the movie doesn't seem to really know
how to
take its time to just allow you to feel
for a movie that is of
such consequence as being you know the
send-off for scarlett johansson we've
spent so much time with her she has such
a legacy
in this iteration of the marvel story it
doesn't
actually feel as culminative for her as
it
should i would argue because without
getting into too many details
yeah it feels like a black widow
adventure but it doesn't feel like the
definitive or the
the real send-off adventure that it
could have like it deals with her
personal origin story but it doesn't
actually live there very much
i felt a big part of what was missing
with this movie
was connecting to natasha and yeah
intimacy and some destruction really
understanding why
this mission and having scenes more
dedicated i felt a lot more for like
elena especially they kind of just did a
lot of assumption on the audience's part
for natasha like you know you'll just
care because you know
yeah yeah you might know some this is
about i remember some
i remember the context this is a notably
bad situation it's easy to get on board
with stopping and so
but knowing a goal is one thing but
feeling why
of the goal is a whole other subject and
joining the fight with your
hero everything is there everything they
need for equality
for truly impactful story is there but
ultimately yeah
it's all right but yeah guys i would
still say check out our reaction if you
want
what i will end with this is there's
gonna be some things in this movie
there's gonna be some things in this
movie
that for sure will
provoke i'll say it
there's gonna be some things that a
pocket of the internet
[Music]
they're gonna so they're gonna have
they're going to be able to make videos
for days yeah
like i got i got the thing to get mad at
and here we go
yeah ignite the car i got the thing to
be pissed off about here we go
let me rant for an hour live yes
how many of these can i bleed out i'd
still stay watch it because
i don't think they were lazy i think
they put a lot of hard work into this
movie you could tell everyone really
cares and
what i'm hoping for is that we're in the
minority it's a weird thing to say
because
ideally you want people to agree with
you
but i root for the films and i root for
the filmmakers
and and everyone because this is a movie
that sticks a lot like thousands of
people working on for so long and this
movie was delayed forever
i hope that most people really enjoyed
this movie
versus feeling the way we felt there's
to be honest
there's a lot of work to appreciate and
i feel like people who aren't looking
for as much maybe as we are we'll still
have a great time anyway guys
we'll see you thanks
[Music]
oh yeah one thing i'll add you know
there's a post credit scene
and it's one of the best scenes in the
movie
you